[Music]  we can't see it  but we're all trapped inside these  strange repeating loops  billions of people just living out their  lives  oblivious  but this is the moment for you to show  us what is real  i remember this  [Music]  so deja vu  and yet it's obviously all wrong  maybe this isn't the story we think it  is  they taught you good  made you believe their world was all you  deserved  but some part of you knew that was a lie  some part of you remembered what was  real  it's so easy to forget how much noise  the matrix pumps into your head  something else makes the same kind of  noise  war  the most important choice in neil's life  it's not his to make  she believed in me  it's my turn to believe in  [Music]  part of me her like i have been waiting  my whole life for you  [Applause]  if you want to see trinity again  i saw this in a dream  my dream ended here  i still don't know  [Music]  you